[Music]
darlene is in san antonio texas hi
darlene welcome to the ramsay show hey
thank you dave thank you for taking my
call i've been trying to get through
since last friday so i'm really excited
to speak with you
my question is
i put a contract offer in on a
small fixer upper
and it was a cash offer and they were
asking 90 high 90s
and i came in
just slightly below that so they did
accept the offer
and um
basically
basically i was going to buy the house
with the loan i did not get the loan so
i had to terminate the contract within
the three-day termination period
and the seller and the seller's agent
did not like that so they said well
we're still going to hold you to the
contract and the earnest money and my
buyer's agent said she's perfectly
within her three-day
termination period
and um
i did speak with the title company and
the title company the lady who uh
pretty much manages the title company
she's the main person there told me that
you're in your three-day termination
period you did not present the earnest
check and also the contract is full of
holes and there's uh the contract is
incomplete there's two pages missing and
i'm not going to accept the contract
and she asked us what us being my
buyer's agent myself what is your
concern and the buyer's agent said well
they're going to try to hold her liable
for the earnest money and possible
breach of contract
and she said well i don't see how that's
going to happen when i the contract is
dissolved so i just kind of wanted your
thoughts on that
where's the earnest money now
uh it was never presented because i
didn't get my loan so oh so they want to
sue you for the earnest money and for
specific performance
on the contract
okay
um well i'm not an attorney but it
sounds like the title company has looked
at it who looks at contracts every day
and has said this is not an enforceable
situation so
you can sue someone for anything you can
just make up a lie
and sue someone
that's happened to me recently
so it can you can just make up crap okay
and just sue somebody and just right
completely bogus thing that didn't even
occur
and so in your mind this this is a
contract it's bogus it didn't occur but
they could go sue you on it uh the
question is would they win
um and do they really want to write all
the legal checks they got a right to
sell a stinking 90 000 house because
even a state court action is going to
cost them 15 to 25 thousand dollars
in legal
right and the house needed a roof it had
it was just a shell and i thought well
maybe i can afford it a little at a time
and it didn't there was no way i could
come up with the money so i was declined
and i said i i'm sorry but my agent
failed to put that in
um
that the contract was contingent upon
financing
yes
well that's dumber than a rock it was uh
it was she my buyer's agent failed to
include a clause saying that
depending on the loan if the loan is
there i should be contingent upon
financing and she didn't and you're well
i mean you shouldn't have signed it you
should have been able to read where's
the contingency on financing yeah well
you sign it blind yeah the offer was she
said as soon as the offer is accepted
that go it is the contract it becomes
the contract i know so why did you make
an offer that was not contingent upon
financing you and your buyer's agent
ought to have your butts kicked it well
i explained that she didn't she didn't
get that part so i told her my loan did
it was declined so you know there's no
way i can
now you misunderstand me the offer that
you made did not contain
the offer that you made when was
accepted did not contain a contingency
on financing meaning the contract was
not contingent on financing you nor your
buyer's agent made sure it was in there
that was dumb
and that's what i was asking for my
buyer's agent no no i'm asking you
you're the grown-up person that signed
the contract
your buyer's agent was done but so were
you
i mean you said you stepped up into this
trap now i don't know what's the
three-day thing is texas got a three-day
ride of rescission on residential real
estate companies
that's that was their right up in the
offer oh they had they gave you three
days
they gave me three days that was the
first thing on the offer
so
that's the termination period that you
get three days on a cash offer and that
was the seller's write-up so that's
weird too okay and they did not complete
they didn't complete the contract they
left out two pages and if the contract
is not completed then it isn't listen in
every state in the united states a real
estate contract has to be signed by both
parties to fully execute and become a
contract otherwise it's an offer and a
counter offer and it sounds like that
you dealt with the most incompetent
group of people i've heard of in a long
time in the real estate business
none of this is rocket science
and so
yeah i hope you learned your lesson
don't make stuff count on three day
rights of rescission put in there what
this is going on if the deal is
contingent upon financing put it in
there
make it part of the deal it sounds like
they're trying to take advantage of this
this whole they did take advantage of it
and they took advantage of the fact that
there's not a three-day that they're
that the contract wasn't completed
properly so there isn't actually even a
contract so there's two pages missing
it wouldn't be enforceable anyway and
there's no earnest money actually
transferred hands to start with so
you know the whole deal was just really
sounds like they're trying to spook her
into getting some some easy money from
this
they're just mad because she didn't
close that's all it is and and they all
ought to be mad at it themselves for
doing this deal everyone should be all
four parties should have their butts
kicked in this deal it's just horribly
executed
and that's why there's so much
disappointment but i don't think you're
going to get sued and i don't think
they're going to win if you do see you
now i'm not a lawyer you'd have to talk
to a lawyer to be sure
but um
i think your title company person is
maybe the only one that's competent in
the whole discussion here
so
real estate get messy if you don't do it
right guys if listen
not referring to her situation
uh but just in general
i was talking to a real estate agent the
other day when i got my real estate
license in 1978
people used to like consider writing a
contract like
giving their word
like you're gonna keep your word like
it's like when i sign a contract that
says i'm going to do something that
means i gave my word and i'm going to do
it even if i don't like it even if it
hurts my feelings even
whatever i said i was going to do i need
to do that's integrity that's gone
apparently people just walk away from
real estate contracts like they just you
know decided you know i'm gonna go buy
73 pairs of clothes try them all on and
take them back the next day i mean it's
that kind of crap that's the way they
treat house deals now and you know
you're executing a real estate contract
on a house
including our caller but but everybody
else out there more importantly than her
make sure that what you're doing is
something you are able and willing to
follow through on
don't mess with people's lives
you know don't play games
and so uh i sold my personal residence
this year
very expensive property
and um
i took a
huge
earnest might check
for this reason right here
because
i was going to be if they didn't want to
close and want to walk away i was going
to be happy
and put that much money in my pocket and
that earnest money check was camped at
my title company you know and so there's
you know there's just you just cannot
you've got to uh
don't enter into these things
willy-nilly don't enter into these
things on impulse
this is a real estate transaction it's
massive
you know make sure that before you shake
hands and you sign on the dotted line
that you're able and you're willing to
do what that offer says now if the offer
says contingent upon financing you're
unable to get the financing then you're
out of the deal
and that's what should have been done in
this last caller
uh instead of a you know sneaking around
in us out inside of a three-day receipt
write a recession if the offer says
contingent upon accepting the report
from the
home inspector
then when the report comes in
if there's three three dollar things
morally you should close on the house
you know now you have the right
technically to walk away i don't like
the inspection report yeah it's three
three dollar things which means you were
just playing freaking games to start
with and you're screwing around with
somebody's home
now you shouldn't do that
people do it all the time nowadays
though
be careful out there lack of commitment